here is journalist I can actually say
journalist Matt taibi who is one of the
guys that released the Twitter files on
with Joe Rogan talking about how much
money Bill Gates has pumped into media
Outlets I mean again the news business
is so starved for Revenue
um that they'll they'll you know they'll
Bend to anybody basically did you see
that I mean I know Jimmy Dore covered it
but quite a few other people have
realized it now the amount of money the
that Bill Gates has spent on uh
influencing media no I I I did somewhere
in the neighborhood of 300 million
dollars geez he's donated to these
various media organizations
which for sure has some sort of an
impact on how they cover him right well
of course yeah and and look the Once
Upon a Time we were uh I've said it many
times we were trained to know uh that
for instance think tanks right like uh
who they were who was funding them
because think tanks are who get quoted
uh in the New York Times in the
Washington Post right recently examined
nearly 20 000 charitable grants The
Gates Foundation made through the end of
June and found that more than 250
million going towards journalism
receipts included news operations like
the BBC NBC Al Jazeera propublica
National Journal of the Guardian
Univision medium the financial times the
Atlantic Texas Tribune Gannett
Washington monthly lamonde Le Monde is
that I say it yeah and uh the center for
investigative reporting and as a
reporter you may not may or may not be
aware of all the different ways that
money will get in you know work its way
into the business but unconsciously it
just sort of seeps in like right and
that's how it works like you nobody
comes and tells you well don't cover
this
um well maybe they do now actually uh or
or you know take this approach to
covering education you what ends up
happening is you just kind of get a feel
based on the reaction of your Editor to
whatever pitch you're giving at the
moment I think taibi's last point there
is the interesting one when Gates gives
this money so 250 million dollars to
those organizations I mean you heard the
list there like they're basically all
leftist organizations and then they just
so happen to be in line with all of
gates feelings about climate change and
the world economic forum and everything
else you know that is in stark contrast
ladies and gentlemen to the way we do
the Reuben report here you know how we
do it we're fan funded that's it I don't
get money from anybody else and nobody
that does fund us on locals has any
control over my content I don't even
know what everyone who's watching this
political beliefs are and that's just
fine right if I started taking money I
mean really just try to think about this
for a second if Bill Gates called us up
and said hey Dave you know you've been a
little critically a little critical of
me lately but I can tell you're a decent
guy and I'm a decent guy so we like to
give you five hundred thousand dollars a
year for a couple years and you just
keep doing the show to the best of your
ability do you think I might be less
critical of Bill Gates then so do you
see how this thing operates it's not
that they sit them down that's how you'd
be saying although maybe they do now
because it's become so Brazen but this
is what they do and this is what we have
seen
pharmaceutical companies and virtually
every big machine entity do they buy
everything
[Music]
foreign